I used to run away and on Sunday pack
his own parachute go up in the trip
trapeze of a balloon and jump at county
fairs under somebody else's name because
grandma would have had a fit and falling
in it had she known him he was the
youngest lieutenant in the
spanish-american war and was on General
Colby staff he was in the Signal Corps
Air Service in World War one and was
overseas as the chief maintenance
officer at Roma rantin incident and
colony bell they overhauled engines and
he tells many interesting stories of
those days he's managed to get the Kitty
Hawk in 19:3 which was most unexpected
he'd gone down there with a friend of
his in fact it was Barney Oldfield 14th
of December well we just saw the back
end of it sticking on this barn and they
said here's our flying machine oh I said
it alone machine they said no it's our
flying machine well it was a good darn
good big kite that's what I thought it
was we had a little bit of trouble with
the ignition that was making break
nothing but two pieces of metal cracking
together and we got to go in and Wilbur
said let's try it well he had built a
track in weather up this hill and under
this airplane over one wheel and it
fitted in the strike we got a tough the
hill and got her started up running all
right and we'll lead down to flood
scared with his arms and feet but I said
let's go we shove it off he was yelling
alright let's go let's go
and it went
I could run as fast as it was running
when it left the ground
I knew the flying it was late enough and
they had power I could fly a barn doors
had enough far he was it for the
Philadelphia ledger I think it was he
said what are they going to do with it I
said they're going to show it to the
dear public sell it to the government
and build a lot of someday oh he saved
your crazy nail goodbye